et désolé de vous avoir fait attendre un
petit peu mais on était sur un sujet
assez important qui est celui du cadre
financier pluri-annuel de l'Union
européenne donc pas sans
conséquence pour les les mois et les
années à venir donc nous allons chers
collègues à présent nous pencher sur le
financement à long terme des ambitions
européennes qui qui repose sur une
institution européenne qui est dédiée la
Banque européenne d'investissement je
remercie donc son vice-président monsur
roise Fayol d'avoir accepté notre
sollicitation pour cette audition qui
s'inscrit dans une tradition désormais
bien établie par mes
prédécesseurs la Banque européenne
d'investissement occupe une place
essentielle dans l'architecture
européenne et parfois méconnue malgré sa
surface financière Nadia Nadia calvinho
sa présidente vient d'annoncer les
résultats annuel du groupe bei en 2023
ce sont près de 88 milliards d'euros de
nouveaux financement que la BEI a
consenti à l'appui de plus de 900
projets à fort impact qui ont contribué
à stimuler la compétitivité la stabilité
et le leadership climatique en Europe
ces 88 milliards se répartissent en
quatre quarts presque égaux entre
soutien aux PME soutien l'innovation au
numérique et au capital humain appui aux
villes et régions durables et appui aux
ressources naturell et énergie
renouvelable en outre la Bui continue
d'investir plus de 100 milliards dans
l'Union européenne pour moitié dédié à
la transition climatique pour un 5è aux
énergies propres et le reste pour la
cohésion de l'Union monsieur le
Président nous serions intéressés de
mieux comprendre derrière ce tableau à
grand trait de son action la stratégie
d'investissement de la Bui la façon dont
elle sélectionne ses projets les projets
qu'elle soutient et surtout comment elle
entend en plus de ses actions déjà nbre
renforcer son rôle d'appui de la
sécurité de la défense européenne comme
le lui a demandé le Conseil européen de
décembre dernier nous souhaiterions
aussi vous entendre sur le champ
géographique d'intervention de la Bui
notamment en appui aux pays candidats
particulièrement l'Ukraine bien sûr et
les pays des des Balcans occidentaux
mais aussi en appui au voisinage sud de
l'Union et au Royaume-Uni qui n'est
certes plus au capital de la banque mais
où celle-ci continue d'intervenir enfin
nous sommes aussi désireux d' équer avec
vous les enjeux de la gouvernance de la
banque non seulement à la suite du
brexit mais aussi dans la perspective
d'un prochain élargissement de l'Union
pourriez-vous également aborder la
contribution de la Bui au respect des
règles éthiques et à la lutte contre la
corruption à la fois dans son activité
de près et dans la gouvernance interne
de l'institution comment
appréhendez-vous notamment le projet
d'organe éthique européen don la
Commission européenne propose la
création et qui concerne la BEI comme
les les grandes institutions européennes
sur lequel nous menons un travail avec
Claude Kerne et Didier Marie d'ailleurs
actuellement je m'arrête là certains que
les rapporteurs vous interrogeront de
manière plus pointue sur ces divers
sujets et sur d'autres mais je vous
laisse la parole pour un propos liminire
je vous remercie
oui c'est de l'autre côté merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président et merci beaucoup
pour votre invitation euh à venir ce
matin devant devant votre commission
pour parler de la Banque européenne
d'investissement je vais je vais essayer
d'être bref mais vous avez soulevé
beaucoup de beaucoup de sujets euh et je
vais commencer par rappeler ce que c'est
que la Banque européenne
d'investissement qui est une institution
qui a été créée par le traité de Rome
donc comme la Commission européenne ou
la cour de de justice et euh dont les
États de l'Union européenne sont
actionnaires euh donc nous sommes une
banque publique et nous avons une
capacité de prêt qui est qui est faite
pour contribuer à des opérations qui ont
un intérêt européen tel que vous avez
rappelé nos priorités d'investissement
en faveur des PME de
l'innovation des villes et des régions
durables et de de l'énergie
euh on est une banque de projet donc on
finance des projets on finance pas d'êes
budgétairees ou d'ides sectoriell et on
finance des projets que ce soit par
nous-même ou en en liaison
avec avec des partenaires notamment les
partenaires clés que sont la Caisse des
Dépôts le groupe Caisse des Dépôts donc
la Caisse des dépôts et et BPI France on
vient de fêter les les 10 ans de de
notre partenariat avec eux et on finance
avec avec ce groupe C des dépôt à peu
près 1 milliard d'euros de projet par an
pour les aider dans le développement des
priorités de la Caisse des dépôts dans
les territoires notamment en faveur du
logement social
euh et puis juste un dernier mot pour
notre fonctionnement interne nous sommes
donc une une banque donc nous empruntons
pour prêter et euh nous empruntons pour
prêter nous sommes notés triple A par
les agences de notation ce qui nous nous
permet d'avoir des conditions
financières extrêmement favorables et de
d'emprunter sur des durées extrêmement
longues et comme notre objectif comme
banque publique n'est pas de maximiser
le
profit nous nous faisons bénéficier les
projets que nous finançons de ces bonnes
conditions financières et c'est aussi
pour cela que que que cette banque qui
est une banque
d'ingénieurs est est reconnue aussi est
reconnu aussi en
Europe euh c'est aussi pour cela je je
le dis sur les questions de défense
c'est un sujet sur lequel on est
extrêmement attentif qui est la manière
dont les investisseurs
perçoivent les priorités de la BEI en
matière de d'action dans le domaine de
la défense peut-être qu'on y reviendra
on y reviendra plus plus plus
précisément alors moi je voudrais
insister sur deux choses d'abord les
évolutions qu'on a connu au cours des
dernières années et et puis peut-être un
mot sur les les résultats qui ont été
qui ont été annoncés et leur traduction
en France et puis peut-être juste
brièvement sur l'activité qu'on a en
dehors d'Europe parce qu'on a une petite
partie de notre activité qui finance des
des projets en dehors d'Europe ça
représente à peu près entre 10 et 15 %
de ce qu'on de ce qu'on fait et pour
l'essentiel dans les pays soit
d'accession soit du
[Musique]
voisinage la BEI elle a connu deux
évolutions
an qui correspondent à à ce qu'on a
perçu comme des des besoins en Europe
pour essayer d'aider les financements la
première c'est essayer d'avoir des
investissements qui sont plus
risqués après la la la crise du début
des enfin 2008 à 2012 on on a bien vu
que l'une des difficultés en Europe
c'était la difficulté pour les
institutions financières à prendre du
risque et on a on a donc mis en place
avec la Commission européenne ce qu'on a
appelé le plan Junker qui est une un
plan qui vise à financer des projets qui
sont plus
risqués que ceux qu'on aurait qu'on
aurait financé normalement et qui nous
ont permis d'être plus présent dans le
domaine de
l'innovation et si je reprends et et on
continue sur cette lancée dans le cadre
de de de l'instrument de l'instrument
actuel invest euu alors si je peux
prendre deux exemples de
cela on a contribué très largement à
l'initiative
repoweru qui est donc de d'augmenter
très fortement pour nous 45 milliards
d'euros en plus d'ici 2027 des
investissements dans le domaine de
l'énergie renouvelable de l'efficacité
énergétique de l'innovation dans le
domaine
énergétique avec comme objectif aussi
d'augmenter l'indépendance et
l'autonomie européenne en matière en
matière énergétique
et l'année dernière on a financé 21
milliards d'euros d'investissement dans
ce secteurl et c'est souvent des
investissements qui sont investissements
risqués notamment en matière
de de batterie électrique qu'on a pu
financer que ce soit un très gros projet
qui s'appelle norsvolt qui est dans le
le nord de la Suède ou des projets en
France on a financé deux des
trois très grosses usines de batterie
électrique qui se monte dans le nord de
la France euh AC pour un montant de 450
millions d'euros et on finance ça
devrait être signé très prochainement
vers cor pour pour à peu près 650
millions d'euros donc c'est des volumes
très importants euh mais sur des enjeux
euh d'autonomie stratégique européenne
et d'innovation qui sont très importants
également puis la deuxième initiative
que je voulais mentionné c'est une
initiative qui part d'une proposition
franco-allemande
il y a 2 ans qui vise à essayer de
favoriser le le le développement de ce
qu'on a appelé les entreprises qui
ont qui ne sont plus des start-ups qui
sont maintenant plus proche du niveau
des des des ETI et qui souvent ont du
mal à se financer à ce stade làà parce
que les besoins sont très important et
que le risque c'est qu'ils aillent se
financer aux États-Unis et donc pour
cela il y a eu intiative qui a été prise
qui
s'appelle une initiative pour favoriser
des champions européens de de la
technologie et qui se met en place avec
un engagement de la BEI de 1 milliard
d'euros donc on a augmenté et on a
vraiment essayé d'augmenter le volume
d'activité qu'on prend avec un niveau de
risque plus élevé et puis le deuxième
évolution qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a
vraiment mise en place c'est de
transformer la Banque européenne
d'investissement de banques de l'Union
européenne en banque du climat de
l'Union européenne et pour ça on a pris
des engagements qui sont des engagements
importants alors c'est c'est pas
totalement totalement nouveau qu'on
fasse des des opérations dans le domaine
climatique mais on a donné comme
ambition d'avoir d'ici 2025 au moins la
moitié de nos financements en matière
climatique et en réalité en alors ça
recouvre les énergies renouvelables ça
recouvre l'efficacité énergétique ça
recouvre l'innovation ça recouvre
l'adaptation c'est c'est assez large
comme comme champ en réalité on est déjà
en
2023 à 60 % en en Europe et en France on
est entre 65 et 70
%. et puis on a également un objectif
qui est d'essayer de de de faire venir
des investisseurs pour financer le plus
possible d'investissement pour le climat
et
ça on a réussi à financer et pour
l'instant l'objectif c'est d'avoir d'ici
2030 1000 milliards d'euros
d'investissements qui seront les nôtres
plus ceux des investisseurs qui viennent
sur nos projets et on est on est en
ligne avec les objectifs qu'on s'est
fixé donc on est assez confortable sur
l'atteint de cet objectif et puis on on
fait attention aussi à ce que nos
objectifs soient cohérents avec les
accords qui ont été
passés à la COP 21 à Paris en 2015 et
c'est un objectif qui là aussi est est
est est tenu alors vous avez rappelé
monsieur le Président les résultats pour
2023 du du du groupe bei donc 88
milliards d'euros d'investissement euh à
peu près 50 qui sont consacrés au
climat c'est donc un chiffre
considérable et
euh et à peu près 45 % qui sont dans les
régions de
cohésion et comme comme comme vous savez
la la raison première de la création de
la Bui à l'époque par le traité de Rome
c'était une raison de cohésion l'idée
des fondateurs de de des traités était à
l'époque de se dire la Communauté
économique européenne va favoriser
fortement le développement économique il
y a un risque pour les régions
périphériques à l'époque c'était surtout
l'Italie du Sud qui était qui était
consid la cohésion reste pour nous un
objectif un objectif très très important
en France je vais peut-être dire un mot
sur ce qu'on a financé en 2000 en
[Musique]
2023 la France est le deuxème pays
bénéficiaire des crédits de des prêt de
la
BEI et elle est le premier bénéficiaire
des prêts de la BEI en faveur du climat
et de l'environnement et ça reste donc
on a financé en l'année dernière c'était
de l'ordre de 11 milliards d'euros cette
année ce sera supérieur à ça on sera de
l'ordre de 12 milliards d'euros et dont
à peu près 7 milliards en faveur de du
climat on est un peu au-dessus de la de
la moyenne européenne et ce confinance
pour le climat ça correspond à deux
types de de différents types de projets
des projets d'innovation j'en ai parlé
avec notamment des des gigafactory ENF
des giga des des usines très très
importantes de de batterie de batterie
électrique
automobile on a aussi souscrit à des
obligations vertes d'entreprises comme
Valéo qui a fait sa première émission
d'obligations verte en 2023 on a financé
des projets dans le domaine de l'énergie
et notamment un projet moi qui que je
trouvais particulièrement intéressant
également à visiter qui était le projet
de l'énergéticien ségie dans la Vienne
qui est un groupe d'entreprises locales
qui a souhaité développer
des des projets à la fois d'énergies
renouvelable et la modernisation de ces
réseaux d'électricité et puis on finance
bien sûr des entreprises comme NG ou
enedis pour des pour des volumes qui
sont important toujours dans le domaine
climatique on est très présent dans le
domaine des transports et des transports
et de la mobilité propre et notamment
dans les territoire et on a financé en
2023 à peu près 2 milillards 7 700
millions EUR au total que ce soit à en
faveur des euh des investissements dans
certaines régions la nouvelle
Aquitaine le centre valdeloire le Grand
Est
pour différentes modernisation de lignes
ferroviair ou de ou de matériel roulant
ou que ce soit pour des des rénovations
de tramois ou de ou de transport urbain
dans des villes comme Nantes Nice tour
et Strasbourg
et puis on a également financé des
projets en faveur de l'efficacité
énergétique des logements notamment en
lien avec la Caisse des dépôts et et et
donc tous ces projets
permettent de à la BEI de d'être un
acteur important en France du soutien
aux énergies aux énergies renouvela et
au projet en faveur de la lutte contre
les effets du changement climatique
je me permets juste une dernière chose
sur ce qu'on finance en France en
matière de soutien à l'autonomie
stratégique européenne parce que on a eu
un projet très important qui a été
financé en
2023 dans le domaine des semi-onducteurs
alors on a financé depuis longtemps des
des semill condonducteurs notamment par
l'entreprise franco-italienne
STM et et sur plusieurs milliards de
d'euros au cours des dernières années et
on finance à coll
le le financement d'une usine très
importante de production de
semiconducteur qui s'appelle Global Fund
ris qui est une une entreprise
américaine qui va permettre de produire
à grande échelle des dispositifs de
semionducteur et qui est vraiment en
ligne avec les initiatives européennes
qui ont été prises dans ce domainelà euh
et cela permet de contribuer non
seulement à la capacité européenne de
euh d'autonomie en matière de de de de
puce et de semic-conducteur mais aussi
des créations d'emploi importantes
puisque là on parle de jusqu'à 1000 €
d'emploi créé et je je pense que c'est
c'est
important je dis juste un mot parce que
j'ai été trop long sur notre activité en
dehors
d'Europe alors nous avons financé en
2023 un peu plus de 8 milliards d'euros
en dehors d'Europe avec comme je vous le
disais des priorités qui sont les
priorités euh euh de de de l'Union
européenne nous sommes membre de ce
qu'on appelle l'équipe Europe qui est
qui a été mise en place par la
Commission européenne pour mieux
coordonner les acteurs européens qui soi
multilatéraux comme nous la berde ou
bilatéraux comme la FD euh et nous
sommes aussi une membbres de la
communauté de ce qu'on appelle les
banques de développement qui sont des
banques de développement multilatéral
comme comme la Banque mondiale euh sur
ces projets en dehors d'Europe on a là
aussi une partie importante de d'action
en faveur de la lutte contre les effets
du changement climatique et en
particulier en faveur de l'adaptation
c'est des projets qu'on essaie de
développer notamment notamment sur le
continent africain en Ukraine plus
précisément nous sommes un partenaire de
l'Ukraine depuis
2014 et depuis l'invasion euh depuis le
début de l'invasion russe nous avons
financé en Ukraine à peu près 2
milliards d'euros de projets euh et nous
sommes un partenaire important de
l'Ukraine dans le domaine euh des
relations avec les municipalités et les
infrastructures qui sont la la force
traditionnelle de la BEI c'est le
financement des infrastructures euh et
nous avons mis en place un un fond
fiduciaire euh en faveur de l'Ukraine
qui est soutenu par les étatsmembres et
la Commission européenne avec des
engagements qui sont de 400 millions
d'euros euh en 203 et qui vont nous
permettre dans le dans la durée
d'augmenter notre capacité de soutien à
à l'Ukraine et nous le faisons en
étroite coordination bien sûr avec nos
partenaires multilatéraux comme la
Banque mondiale ou la berde compte tenu
des des enjeux et et des besoins voilà
je je m'arrête là monsieur le Président
merci petite question je me posais avant
de passer peut-être la parole à
Christine Lavarde donc oui peut-être non
pas forcément bon donc je passerai la
parole aux uns et aux
autres vous vous terminiez en fait par
par les prêts à l'Ukraine et nous on se
posait la même question par rapport aux
institutions vous garantissez comment
vos prêts c'est c'est l'union qui vous
les
garantit alors il y a sur sur des sur
les prêts à l'Ukraine c'est des prêts
extrêmement risqués et nous on a une
institution triple A donc on doit
on a un volume de ce qu'on peut
financer sur nos ressources propres même
si on est institution très capitalisé
qui qui est limité et donc on a besoin
de la
garantie en gros on peut on on a une
garantie qui qui qui représente à peu
près 70 % des des prêts qu'on fait les
garanties elle peut être soit de la
Commission européenne soit des
étatsmembres et sur l'Ukraine on a les
deux et nous question Christine on
l'intègre REP pas au CFP nous tout ça
non ça c'est ces garanties d'emprunt
sont sortis du elles sont pas de dans
les emprunts que nous on a vu qui sont
les emprunt de la Commission et
d'ailleurs si j'embrille sur la question
des garanties là vous nous avez égrainé
un certain nombre de champs d'activité
dans lequel vous intervenez vous avez cé
la France mais je suppose que les
actions sont les mêmes auprès des autres
États-membres est-ce qu'il y a certains
de ces prêts qui font l'objet de de
garantie
d'État alors de garantie d'État c'est
assez rare il y en a eu quelques-uns
dans le cadre des des des prenes de de
qui ont été mis en place très récemment
euh dans le cadre de de de d'uneune
initiative européenne euh qui s'appelle
RRF euh qui qui vise à essayer de
d'augmenter notre les financements dans
dans le cadre de la crise suite au covid
mais en général les les les prêts qu'on
les les prêts qu'on fait euh sont soit
soit sur nos ressources propres c'est
c'est d'ailleurs la majorité soit quand
ils ont un niveau de risque plus élevé
avec une garantie de la Commission
européenne dans le cadre de budget
investiu par exemple et et ça ça nous
permet d'ugmenter le volume d'activité
qu'on aurait pu sinon qu'on aurait dû
faire beaucoup plus limité par le par le
niveau de risque des
projet merci on va
entamer les questions je rappelle aussi
que l'audition est captée bien sûr vidéo
captée si vous le voulez conformément à
la tradition de notre commission on
prend par trois questions puis comme ça
vous vous pouvez répondre
tranquillement Dominique de leè pour
commencer André richichard se prépare
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président vous avez évoqué le
travail de la BEI sur la question des
énergies renouvelable vous avez
mentionné les batteries je voulais
savoir quelle était votre
votre engagement sur le nucléaire et
deuxème question nous avons reçu la
semaine dernière le commissaire breton
qui nous a fait part des ambitions de la
Commission dans le domaine de
l'industrie de la défense et quand même
une ambition à 100 milliards est-ce que
vous êtes associé à cette démarche et
quelle est votre analyse du besoin de
fin je vous
remercie
prépare merci Monsieur le vice-président
pour votre rapport je me permet deux
questions complémentaires concernant
plus particulièrement vos interventions
hors Union Européenne première question
sur le partenariat
oriental je m'adresse au Président nous
n'avons plus depuis quelques temps une
vision très très claire et
concrète de l'évolution du du
Partenariat oriental à l'heure actuelle
pour 36000 raisons euh
intervenez-vous à l'égard de ces pays du
Partenariat oriental
euh plus particulièrement à l'égard d'un
pays qui n'a n'a n'a pas de de contrat
d'association avec l'Union européenne où
on voit encore moins clair c'est par
exemple
l'Azerbaïjan deuxème et et le caschant à
quelle hauteur lorsque vous intervenez
bien sûr dans ces différents pays du
Partenariat oriental 2uxè question
concernant
les candidats à à l'entrée à l'Union
européenne donc vous savez
que la liste s'est étaufé récemment de
de de de trois pays est-ce que vous
intervenez à leur égard je vise
particulièrement indépendamment de
l'Ukraine bien sûr un pays qui fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts
mais qui a d'énormes besoins c'est par
exemple la Moldavie sans même parler de
la Géorgie je vous
remercie
merci tout d'abord merci de de cet
exposé j'ai l'impression que au fil et
malheureusement à l'ône des crise
successives que que connaissent que
connaît l'Union européenne alors il y a
eu la crise sanitaire maintenant il y a
les crises liées au conflits on prend
conscience et les européens prennent
conscience que l'Union européenne est un
grand marché de consommateurs mais doit
aussi reprendre la main sur les enjeux
de production liés aux enjeux aussi de S
souverineté dans des secteurs
stratégiques vous avez cité les les
semi-onducteurs on pourrait citer la
santé évidemment l'énergie dans quelle
mesure votre activité à l'ône de de ces
de la peut-être du renforcement de ces
grands enjeux évolue est-ce que vous
vous repositionnez sur ces secteurs
stratégiques et comment vous pouvez
aider à relever avec d'autres
partenaires ces enjeux de de financement
des secteurs productifs parce que c'est
c'est bien l'enjeu qui est devant nous
actuellement merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président c'est des des questions
extrêmement importantes donc je vais
prendre un petit peu de temps pour pour
répondre si vous voulez bien sur le le
nucléaire alors le le nucléaire est est
éligible au financement de la BEI euh
c'est à l'évidence une énergie
décarbonée
et et donc
que le nucléaire fait partie des
investissements que la BEI peut
faire dans la réalité de ce que je vois
il y a des investissements dans le
nucléaire qui sont financé par la BEI
euh notamment en matière de sécurité
nucléaire euh et en
2023 on a financé en particulier un
investissement important en Roumanie
euh
ce qui est vrai c'est que ces
investissements font tous les projets
qu'on présente au conseil
d'administration sont votés par le
conseil d'administration où il y a les
représentants des 27 états- membres
et sur ces thématique du nucléaire je ne
vous diraiis pas que ce sont les débats
les plus consensuels et sereins
euh donc oui on peut financer des
projets nucléaires et oui c'est
compliqué euh de les euh de les faire
approuver par le par le conseil
d'administration mais moi j'ai vu passer
plusieurs projets nucléaires depuis que
je suis euh vice-président euh à à
Luxembourg j'en profite pour dire un mot
parce que vous aviez parlé de
Royaume-Uni euh alors le Royaume-Uni a a
donc pris la décision de sortir de
l'Union européenne et donc de sortir de
la Banque européenne d'investissement et
ça a donné lieu à une augmentation de
capital puisque le Royaume-Uni avait un
un comme premier actionnaire de la BEI
avec à même niveau que l'Allemagne et la
France et l'Italie
euh un capital d'à peu près 40 milliards
d'euros pour l'essentiel qui n'était pas
été déboursé qui était donc appelable et
il a fallu une augmentation de capital
qui a été approuvée par les parlements
des des 27 autres États-membres pour
nous permettre de euh ne pas voir notre
activité s'effondré puisque nous pouvons
prêter en fonction du capital que que
dont dont dont nous disposons
nous ne faisons plus aujourd'hui de de
projet au
Royaume-Uni voilà donc voilà sur le
nucléaire sur la défense alors on on a
une initiative en faveur de du
financement de la
défense et on finance à peu près chaque
année 1 milliard d'euros de projet dans
le domaine de la
défense et ça peut toucher des projets
de de recherche et développement
entreprise je pense notamment à Leonardo
en Italie par exemple ou ça peut être
des projets en en matière de drone ou de
cyber sécurité ce qui est important pour
nous c'est deux éléments qu'on regarde
quand on finance des projets dans le
domaine de la défense il faut d'abord
que ce soit des projets qui ont un un ce
qu'on appelle un double usage
c'est-à-dire un qui sont utilisés à la
fois pour des raisons militaires et pour
des raisons
civiles c'est c'est le cas par exemple
de souvent de recherche sur des
hélicoptères ou
voilà et à ce momentl on peut on peut le
financer puis la deuxième la deuxième
chose que je j'ai dit en introduction
c'est une des choses à laquelle on est
extrêmement attentif puisque nous on a
besoin
d'emprunter pour pour financer nos
projets et et donc on est très dépendant
des marchés des capitaux et des
investisseurs c'est qu'il y a un certain
d'investisseurs qui nous disent autant
on comprend qu'un
État doit financer des projets de
défense France autant on considère
qu'une institution internationale
financière comme la BEI ou d'autres
banques de développement ça n'est pas sa
vocation et donc il faut qu'on regarde
toujours attentivement la manière dont
les investisseurs et la communauté des
investisseurs apprécie
le notre action en matière de défense
pour être sûr que au total ce soit pas
l'ensemble de nos projets qui qui qui
souffrent de de taux d'intérêt sur le
sujet évoqué sans sans sans couper le
fil des des questions posées nous avons
eu le commissaire breton en audition ici
la semaine dernière et ça a été
évoqué la la le souhait notamment du
commissaire mais aussi de la commission
générale et du Conseil d'accélérer la
production notamment de munition euh ça
a été confirmé d'ailleurs par le
Président de la République le lendemain
ou le surlendemain de de l'audition dans
une visite qu'il avait faite est-ce que
vous d'après ce que vous nous dites vous
rentrez pas dans le champ d'action
c'està-dire
que la capacité l'augmentation de la
capacité de production elle se fera sans
vous alors nous ce qu'on ce qu'on
finance
c'est c'est en augmentation en terme de
volume de ce qu'on peut financer dans le
domaine de de d'investissement qui sont
liés au monde de la défense ce qu'on ne
finance pas aujourd'hui c'est des
investissements qui sont purement
militaires
euh et et ça c'est nous on est pour ça
dépendant de nos actionnaires
aujourd'hui on n pas cette cette cette
capacité là sur le le le Partenariat
oriental et sur et sur les pays les pays
candidats alors on a investi au cours
des 10 dernières années dans cette dans
cette région à peu près 10 milliards
d'euros donc à peu près 1 milliard
d'euros par an donc c'est c'est c'est
c'est important ça inclut bien sûr
l'Ukraine pour lesquel l'investissement
est particulièrement important puisque
au cours des dernières années on a
investi 6 milliards d'euros en
Ukraine on on est complètement en ligne
avec les priorités qui ont été adoptées
en Europe en 2021 sur sur les
investissements dans le dans le
Partenariat oriental et on essaie
d'augmenter nos
investissements et notre activité
dans les trois pays nouvellement
candidats que sont donc la Moldavie
l'Ukraine et et la geéorgie avec aussi
un engagement fort de la BEI d'être
présent en
Arménie voilà on a on est présent à Kief
nous avons un représentant de la de la
BEI qui est qui est sur place avec une
une petite équipe ce qui nous permet
aussi d'être d'être plus proche des de
nos de nos de nos partenaires de nos
partenaires
Ukrainiens
euh sur le domaine de la souveraineté
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
alors c'est devenu une priorité
importante en en pour la Banque
européenne d'investissement
euh traditionnellement on était assez
présent dans le domaine des
infrastructure de santé on reste assez
présent dans ce domaine là notamment il
y a eu un projet de plusieurs centaines
de millions d' qui a été qui qui a été
mis en place en faveur de l'hôpital de
Nantes l'année dernière mais ce qui a
vraiment ce qui est vraiment monté en
puissance c'est des investissements très
risqués dans des domaines de
laamtech ce qu'on appelle donc la
technologie les les les petites
entreprises qui sont présentes dans le
domaine de la technologie médicale
et on a financé en en en France un
certain nombre de ces de ces entreprises
là euh je pense notamment à Carmat euh
et et l'année dernière on a j'ai été
signé moi à Bordeaux pour vous donner
juste un exemple mais il y en a beaucoup
qu'on a financé on pouit vous passer la
liste bien
sûr un projet qui s'appelle germitech
qui est une une petite entreprise qui a
mis en place un système extrêmement
performant pour essayer de réduire les
maladies
nosocomial donc tout ce genre il y a il
y a aussi on a on avait financé je crois
que ça s'appelle a à Dijon ou à côté de
Dijon qui est une entreprise qui a
beaucoup développé des technologies pour
essayer de lutter contre la maladie de
nche la maladie du foie grve euh donc
tout ça on espère comme ça arriver à
financer ce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle des
euh des des des champions européens dans
leur dans leur catégorie qui puissent
qui puissent effectivement contribuer
aussi à notre à notre souveraineté et
j'ai un exemple en particulier en tête
qui n'est pas en France mais on on avait
financé une une
entreprise en Allemagne qui avait une
technologie à l'époque qui était
considérée on a nous dans les dans notre
équipe un ou deux
médecins qui qui qui évaluent les
projets considér comme
révolutionnaire laquelle moi à l'époque
j'avais pas compris grand-chose qui
était utile pour le traitement des
cancers et cette technologie c'est la
technologie de la RN
messager et cette entreprise c'est
biontech et quand bitech est venu nous
voir au début de la crise covid en
disant on pense que notre technologie
marche contre le covid euh on les a
également financés donc c'est c'est
vraiment des projets qu'on essaie de
développer parce qu'on pense que c'est
important aussi pour notre souveraineté
européenne alors quand vous financez des
projets comme cela de de de tech médical
vous regardez un petit peu selon
l'organisation des des États-membres
bien sûr et en France on a une
organisation pour financer ses projets
déjà au travers France France France
2030 euh et puis les IHU les instituts
hospital universitaires est-ce que vous
vous regardez comment est organiser déjà
le financement de ces projets avant
avant d'aller dessus et en particulier
sur les IHU je
pensais alors euh on on on travaille
bien sûr avec France 2030 de manière de
manière assez assez importante hein
c'est aussi un moyen pour nous d'avoir
des d'avoir des financements
complémentaires au nôtres
avec les IHU moi j'ai un exemple en tête
de ce qu'on avait de ce qu'on a fait je
donc c'est c'est je sais pas si c'est de
manière générale je crois pas que ce
soit une politique mais en revanche on
par exemple à Montpellier on travaille
avec ce ce ce centre hospitalier et en
liaison avec une entreprise qui
notamment a développé un système de de
transmission des des des de diffusion
des médicaments de manière extrêmement
lente dans le corps qui permet d'avoir
voir euh beaucoup moins de de prise de
médicaments par exemple pour des des
malades de la de la schizophrénie C
entreprise s'appelle mincel est
extrêmement performante et d'ailleurs
considérée dans un pays comme les
États-Unis comme une entreprise qu'
regarde de très près merci allez on
reprend le cycle de question donc Renand
legleu se prépare Louis-Jean
Nicola merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le le
vice-président la question que je
souhaiterais vous poser j'ai eu
l'occasion de la poser au directeur
général de l'Agence française de
développement c'est l'utilisation de
l'euro comme monnaie puissance et
notamment le le le rôle qui vous est
confié en ce sens dans vos
investissement hors de l'espace de de
l'euro est-ce que vous avez comme
objectif un objectif peut-être
secondaire qui serait celui de l'usage
de l'euro comme monnaie parce que
évidemment quand vous financez des des
projets que ce soit en Afrique ou
ailleurs vous pouvez faire le choix du
dollar ou d'une autre monnaie et donc
est-ce que tout simplement dans dans les
les montages financiers que vous opérez
vous tentez de privilégier l'usage de
l'euro ou est-ce que ce n'est absolument
pas un objectif qui vous est fixé il me
semble personnellement vous l'avez
rappelé que la la BEI étant créé par le
le traité de Rome cela pourrait être
l'un des objectifs que on lui confie je
vous
remercie
j'ai peu de questions parce que
Dominique deè a posé deux questions sur
le nucléaire et sur le problème
militaire la seule chose moi ce qui ce
qui qui m'inquiète et au niveau de
peut-être de l'Europe et je sais pas si
la Bui peut être intéress enfin
partenaire là-dedans c'est si Monsieur
Trump décide d'arrêter son soutien à
l'Ukraine au mois de novembre prochain
qui va financer comment on va financer
l'armement de l'Europe s'il veut prendre
la place de des États-Unis moi je suis
extrêmement inquiet sur sur cette
situationl j'ai C comprendre que vous
financiez pas l'armement ce sont les
états avant que les États se mettent
d'accord à trouver la moyen de le
financer je sais pas comment je sais pas
comment on va faire euh pour cela je
suis pas sûr que vous soyez remboursé
euh des des prêts de l'Ukraine euh à
terme non je voulais juste vous demander
sur le la B8 donc finance en partenariat
systématiquement avec euh les des des
des banque publique ou autres comme la
caiss des dépôts et donc est-ce que les
les actions sont systématiqu iquement
apporté par C ces groupes financiers
dans chaque pays où vous prenez
desinitiatives directement avec les
entreprise
oui merci monsieur le Président oui
effectivement on doit saluer je dirais
l'évolution très positive des activités
de la BEI tel qu'on le constate ces
dernières années je crois que l'ambition
qui avait été annoncé en 2020 si je me
rappelle bien que d'en faire la banque
européenne du climat
si on regarde la la trajectoire le
niveau de soutien à l'action en faveur
du climat et et la durabilité
environnementale non seulement les
chiffres je crois que c'est pas c'est
plus de 50 % de l'activité de prêt
globale on est aujourd'hui à plus de 54
% me semble-t-il on peut pas dire du
tout que l'action de la Bui ça serait du
du green washing ça c'est c'est clair
alors sur bon le le nucléaire a été
évoqué donc vous avez dit que c'est
c'est pas consensuel à votre conseil
d'administration chez nous aussi pas
tout à fait pas complètement et je crois
qu'effectivement si si la Bui contribue
à financer des des des projets de de
mise en conformité de sécurité des
infrastructure nucléaire déjà existante
ce qui est évidemment
nécessaire par contre je crois qu' qu'il
serait pas évident et pas raisonnable de
d'engager des financements conséquen sur
de nouvelles capacités nucléaires parce
que ce qui est important c'est
c'est c'est l'essort des renouvelables
auquel la BEI apporte une contribution
essentielle et c'est ça dans les 15 à 20
années à venir qui est le plus SR moyen
avec l'efficacité énergétique et la
sobriété de tenir nos trajectoire
bacarbone deux question sur les les
projets hors UE
euh il y a un exemple récent qui a été
porté par
roxfam concernant le financement par la
la Banque européenne d'investissement
d'hôpitaux privés dans les pays du Sud
et et du fait de de financement
impliquant des des intermédiaires
financiers des des structures privées
qui ont manifestement mal géré les fonds
européens on a des des exemples un peu
scandaleux de de de patients et qui en
sortent et sauré financièrement qu'on
garde contre leur gré tant qu'ils
peuvent pas régler leur factur donc
comment éviter que des situations ne se
prododuisent que la BEI se retrouve à
financer les établissements de ce type
comment contrôler l'action des
intermédiaires tout tout au long de la
la mise en œuvre des projets et puis sur
la question de la la l'action de la BEI
pour la biodiversité je sais que les
vous avez évolué dans vos standards
environnementaux vous êtes passé d'une
politique aucune perte
nette de biodiversité à une politique de
aucune perte tout court de biodiversité
et dans ce cadre- là le projet enfin le
le la la à Madrid en cœur de Madrid donc
le le le projet de ligne métro qui a
déraciné je crois un millier d'arbres on
comprend mal comment il peutv s'inscrire
dans cette évolution de la politique en
faveur de la
biodiversité merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président alors
euh sur sur l'euro comme comme comme
monnaie puissance c'est c'est bien sûr
un objectif de de l'institution bei euh
et c'est aussi un objectif qui nous est
fixé dans certains mandats de de la
Commission européenne euh pour lesquels
on doit euh on a des objectifs de
décaissement en euros euh et euh je
dirais autant qu'on peut le faire on on
essaie de le de le de le de de de faire
des financements en en euros
euh la limite de
de qu'on trouve souvent c'est d'abord on
a des on a souvent des partenaires euh
euh notamment en dehors d'Europe qui
préfèr être financé dans d'autres
monnaaies dollar ou pas forcément le
dollar d'ailleurs
euh mais je suis je suis d'accord avec
vous en tant que aussi ancien dirigeant
de l'Agence française de la de la dette
euh
laft que c'est une priorité pour essayer
de développer l'euro comme comme comme
monnaie comme monnaie forte
euh alors on a des en réalité on on a
des partenariats qui sont des
partenariats euh importants mais qui
sont pas forcément exclusif c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a deux moyens d'avoir des
projets avec avec la la BEI il y a il y
a des des situations dans lesquelles
euh une entreprise vient voir les
représentants de la BEI en France on a
un bureau de représentation
euh et ça aboutit sur des projets qui
sont financés par la BEI avec en direct
avec ces entreprises-là ou avec ces
collectivités localesl et puis on a des
partenariats avec soit
euh soit la banque
euh soit la la le groupe de la Caisse
des Dépôts donc BPI France la Caisse des
Dépôts elle-même la banque des
territoires et euh CDC habitat euh ou
avec aussi les banques privées pour
lesquelles on finance souvent des
projets
pour essayer de les de de qu' qu'elle
finance encore plus de PR de de prêt en
faveur des
PME et donc il y a les deux en fait
c'estàdire que il y a à la fois des
partenariats qu'on essaie de
développer avec nos partenaires et
notamment nos partenaires institutions
financières et puis il y a des projets
qui sont développés en direct et en
particulier tous les projets dans le
domaine de la santé dont on dont on
parlait c'est des projets qui sont en
général développés en direct par nous
avec avec ces ces entreprises souvent
soit start-up soit de taille
intermédiaire euh alors je je peux pas
vous répondre sur votre l'exemple précis
de de de d'hôpitaux qui privé en dehors
de en dehors de l'Union Européenne ce
qui ce que je peux dire en revanche
c'est que les projets qu'on finance en
dehors de l'Union Européenne suivent le
le même rigueur d'instruction que ceux
qui sont en Europe et en particulier on
a un certain nombre de normes et de
standards européens on défend les les
valeurs européennes sur tous les projets
qu'on qu'on qu'on finance en dehors
d'Europe mais je je j'ai pas de
d'exemple en particulier que que que que
que vous avez
développé la biodiversité c'est un des
un des éléments qu'on souhaite sur
lequel on souhaite mettre l'accent comme
l'adaptation dans le au changement
climatique
euh et vous avez raison de dire qu'on a
eu un un objectif qui qui est qui a été
changé l'année dernière euh de passer de
aucune perte nette à aucune perte en
matière de biodiversité
euh c'est des projets qui sont souvent
biodiversité des projets de plus petite
taille euh et donc pour une institution
comme la BEI qui est une institution qui
finance plutôt des projets vous avez vu
en moyenne de l'ordre de 100 millions
d'euros ça n n'empêche pas de faire des
projets plus petite taille mais c'est
vrai que c'est souvent des projets qui
sont qui sont
difficiles mais je suis convaincu qu'on
va financer plus de projets de
biodiversité dans les dans les
prochaines
années merci on reprend donc Pascal
Gruny se prépare George
patient merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le vice-président moi j'ai une
question sur le financement dans des
investis dans l'immatériel intelligence
artificielle et la chaîne de de bloc
l'archivage
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le vice-président ma question
va porter sur les régions
ultrapériphériques françaises les
départements région de
d'outremer ces territoires d'outremer
ces territoires européens présente
toutes les caractéristiques tous les
critères pour être éligible auprès de la
BU et pourtant il continue à ne pas en
bénéficier malgré un certain nombre
d'annonces faites par le dernier sium
notamment comment vous expliquez
cela merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le vice-président peut-être
pour rebondir sur ce que disait tout à
l'heure mon mon collègue Jacques ferern
j'avait de constat d'abord sur le sur la
question de la décarbonation c'est un
sujet qui qui est important et qui est
attendu je crois par nos concitoyens et
dans lequel nos états sont engagés de
façon différenciée donc je je voulais un
peu entendre votre
euh votre vision et et votre appui sur
notamment les carburants de synthèse il
y a des états qui se sont effectivement
engagés vers les carburants de synthèse
mais aussi vers l'hydrogène puisque
l'hydrogène est devenu un sujet
d'actualité dans beaucoup de territoires
y compris en France puisqu'il y a soit
de la production d'hydrogène vert qui
est souhaitée soit euh de l'hydrogène
blanc c'est-à-dire euh à l'état naturel
qui se trouve dans les sous-sols et pour
lesquels on n'a pas nécessairement une
stratégie développée et précisée et puis
l'autre sujet vous avez parlé de
biodiversité la biodiversité c'est aussi
un un un débat sur nos pratiques et not
notamment notre façon d'occuper le
territoire je pense en particulier vous
savez qu'il y a en France eu le débat
autour du Zéro artificialisation net et
quand on parle du Zéro artificialisation
net il faut le mettre en face de la
rénovation du bâti existant et notamment
de la rénovation énergétique et quelle
est la stratégie de la Bui en la matière
pour soutenir effectivement
ces territoires qui souhaiteraient
s'engager dans cette rénovation
énergétique comme une réponse une des
réponses à la limite de
l'artificialisation
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président alors sur sur l'immatériel euh
bon d'abord c'est une c'est une c'est un
enjeu qu'on regarde nous pour notre
propre notre propre organisation et euh
on on commence à regarder aussi les
financement qu'on pourrait faire dans ce
secteur là ce qu'on a déjà fait c'est
en en chaîne de bloc
une une une opération qui d'ailleurs a
été saluée par les par les marchés
financiers de financement de de
trésorerie de la de la de la BEI qu'on a
fait d'ailleurs en lien avec la Banque
de
France j'en profite pour dire un mot sur
un secteur dont on a pas beaucoup parlé
on finance beaucoup de projets dans le
domaine de la du déploiement de la
5G que ce soit c'est l'année dernière
déjà avec Orange ou avec ilad et on
finance beaucoup de projets dans le
domaine de enfin on essaie de financerô
beaucoup de projets dans le domaine de
l'autonomie stratégique dans le domaine
du numérique et je pense notamment à une
entreprise qui fait un travail assez
formidable qui s'appelle OVH et qui a
développé euh l'idée d'avoir un nuage
qui soit euh ben qui soit pas dans enin
qui soit maîtrisé par des par des
Européens et on a fait un financement
important pour pour pour pour cette
entreprise là alors sur les outres mers
je je je suis
euh
euh je je je suis d'accord avec vous sur
euh le constat que les le les
outremerses comme partie intégrante de
l'Union européenne doiventf sont
éligibles au financement de la BEI et
dans le dans dans l'action qui est la
mienne au
au au quotidien j'essaie toujours de de
porter cette cette voie là et si je
permet de donner quelques exemples on a
financé un certain nombre de projets moi
j'étais il y a récemment à la Réunion où
on a financé un collège par ailleurs
extrêmement intéressant parce que c'est
un collège qui est à énergie positive et
donc
avec avec une une une une conception qui
était particulièrement particulièrement
moderne on a financé aussi avec la
région des des fonds pour aider le dév
dévppement de
PME et on a financé des infrastructures
je pense notamment à la rénovation de
l'aéroport
de de saintd la Réunion et à la nouvelle
route du littoral qui va entre
Saint-Denis et la possession et dans
d'autres territoires on a financé je
pense notamment à la à la
Guadeloupe l'aéroport de la rénovation
de l'aéroport de pointe àapitre et donc
je je je moi je je enfin je pense que on
essaie de de de répondre
euh au au au aux besoins qui nous sont
qui nous sont présentés par par les les
outr-emers mais si vous avez des des des
exemples ou des projets n'hésitez pas à
à à nous à nous en faire part bien bien
sûr
euh bon l'hydrogène c'est une c'est une
priorité importante pour l'Europe donc
c'est une priorité importante pour la
BEI et dans les objectifs qui sont à la
fois d'ailleurs dans notre action en
Europe et en dehors d'Europe donc on a
un certain nombre de projets qu'on
regarde
notamment il y a c'est sorti d'ailleurs
cette semaine mais à la fin de l'année
dernière on a on a signé un un projet
très important en en en Suède pour
financer l'acier vert à à partir
d'hydrogène parce que l'hydrogène l'une
l'une des euh l'une des actions très
importantes qu'on peut trouver à
l'hydrogène c'est notamment que ça
permet la décarbonation des industries
qui sont très fortement émérices et
c'est notamment c'est notamment c'est un
enjeu majeur parce que c'est notamment
là qu'il y a le le que la réduction des
des des émissions peut être peut être
attendu et donc des projets de ce type
là on est vraiment très heureux de
pouvoir de pouvoir les financer on a
aussi euh un projet qu'on a financé pour
fa pour financer la recherche
d'Arcelor toujours dans ce même domaine
et on a des projets qu'on essaie de
développer dans le domaine du ciment des
engrais et cetera
euh et et par ailleurs en dehors
d'Europe on on voit aussi le
développement de de projets notamment en
Afrique euh en faveur de l'hydrogène
qu'on regarde aussi que ce soit en
Égypte en Namibie ou euh ou ou en
Mauritanie et l'efficacité énergétique
pour nous c'est une composante
absolument essentielle de de notre
politique euh de notre politique
énergétique et de de la de l'action de
la de l'action en faveur du euh du
climat euh et on finance donc beaucoup
de projets beaucoup de projets
euh en faveur de l'efficacité
énergétique ou en tout cas qui inclut
une composante d'efficacité énergétique
alors euh on par exemple on a en en
France chaque année de très nombreux
départements et des
régions avec lesquels on signe des
projets pour financer soit la rénovation
soit la construction de nouveaux
collèges ou de nouveau lycée dans ce
cadre là et c'est d'ailleurs une une
demande de nos
partenaires
naturellement il y a toujours une partie
importante qui est consaccré à
l'efficacité énergétique et de la même
façon qu'on le fait dans le domaine de
notre partenariat avec la caissise des
dépôts pour le logement social il y a un
projet que je voudrais mentionner parce
que il est particulièrement il a été
particulièrement intéressant pour nous à
à financer qu'on a fait avec CDC habitat
qui a un projet qui s'appelle je sais
pas si vous le connaissez monsieur le
Président mais qui qui s'appelle ce
qu'il est dans le dans le Pas de Calais
maison et cité euh et ça c'est un projet
extrêmement intéressant qui est la
rénovation et notamment la rénovation
thermique des euh des corons et
notamment exactement notamment al liin
on avait été financé euh et et entre
voilà et et on avait été nous le voir
voir ce projet-l à
dej et et ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est que les corons sont
des bâtiments qui sont classé donc on
peut pas faire de rénovation par
l'extérieur et donc c'est une rénovation
exclusivement par l'intérieur et et nous
on avait été voir des des des des
habitations avant et après et c'est vrai
que c'était assez spectaculaire et
d'ailleurs je me souviens très bien
notamment d'un d'un monsieur qui
habitait dans cette dans cet habitat qui
avait été rénové et qui nous disait
c'est bien de voir que l'Europe fait
quelque chose pour nous donc ça ça fait
partie des priorités de l'Union
européenne pas seulement parce
que parce que c'est ça permet de de de
financer des projets en faveur du
changement climatique mais aussi parce
que ça permet de
montrer que
concrètement l'Europe est là aussi pour
financer des projets qui améliorent la
vie des des citoyens
européens merci pas d'autres questions
non je pense que on a fait le tour
écoutez merci beaucoup pour pour pour
toutes ces
informations on voit aujourd'hui plus
précisément les champs d'action de la
BEI qui à mon avis on regarde d'ailleurs
l'évolution des institutions européennes
et l'élargissement probablement auront
peut-être aussi des des des moments de
transformation parce que on voit que les
investissements vont très vite Pascal
Gruny a parlé de l'intelligence
artificielle on sait très bien que ces
domaines d'activité associés à la santé
associé à l'agriculture on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment euh associé à
l'industrie et à l'énergie en
particulier euh seront euh euh seront
des des grands tournants de de notre
civilisation merci beaucoup à
vous et merci aux collègues qui ont
participé mais on n' pas
fini